Donald Trump's efforts to punish Russia
for its alleged election meddling could
end up hitting American consumers in the
pocket that's because Al iminium imports
are about to get more expensive since
the US Treasurys imposition of sanctions
on aluminium giants Russell in April
fears of a global shortage have been
growing and that's what awkward
pressures on the price Washington
officials have repeatedly pushed back
the deadline for compliance with the
restrictions American firms originally
had to stop doing business with Russell
by late October but that's been extended
to mid-november to allow more time for
talks with Russell's parent company but
despite the apparent determination of
Treasury officials to go ahead with the
sanctions economic experts and critics
say they're damaging to US manufacturing
that have been a strategic failure
economist dr. mom do Salome says the
penalties don't make sense from a
financial standpoint the question is the
United States retreated from these
sanctions in order to help reduce the
prices it shows in my opinion that there
is no ethical basis for you as sanctions
anywhere they are aimed to serve us
interests wherever it is needed what is
coming from the United States is
confusing the White House wants
something the Treasury wants something
else in the final analysis
they reach an agreement on what
sanctions they take but it shows there
is discrepancy of their views on the
imposition of sanctions on countries and
on companies as well as on individuals
sanctions don't serve any purpose the
Americas try to stop the North's trip to
the project of carrying gas under the
Baltic to Germany and the European Union
and it seems that the Nord Stream 2 is
unstoppable
despite the functions on the companies
involved in the financing so in a
nutshell the sanctions reach our
irritants but they don't bite
you